[Music]
nice to see you again with this issue
while you're having on the show first of
all that I got to say I've been very
excited about this movie because man
does this add a whole new layer to
Abraham Lincoln you know what the thing
about is was so great Abraham Lincoln
was already a superhero in his own right
yeah and I feel like every movie is like
a reboot or remake a retake a reshot so
this is like an original idea and it's
fun and it's creative and it's just a
really fun movie well what's funny to me
- is it you think ok Lincoln had to
fight the Civil War he had to draft the
Emancipation Proclamation you know and
while all this is going on he's got to
get to Gettysburg and give the most
famous address of all time it's not so
going on you have you also got a fight
and burn me up I am very tired a rough
enough you know what I mean
Lincoln this must have been like can I
get you've got a lot of stuff going on
but that's why he's considered the
greatest American president of all time
right yeah yeah I mean he didn't try to
make ketchup a vegetable
no come on the good president do you
think this is gonna be a trend now like
they'll be other presidents you know
historical presidents that are hope so
because the thing about it is you know
the educational system is the only
system that hasn't evolved in this
country and I think you know we're in a
situation where we need to introduce
presidents and figures to kids in a
completely different way we need to
introduce them to adults in a different
way so they go home and google them and
figure out Wow Abraham Lincoln really
had a girlfriend will you make Johnson
who was a black dude 1865 there's that
part's true right
there are no FDR's didn't kill zombies
[Laughter]
be so crazy Washington didn't fight
aliens huh
but that would be a cool story it would
be a cool story he came to America yeah
kill sums on yeah I like it okay my
question is when I first heard the title
I have to tell you
knowing Tracy Morgan the way I do in the
way a lot of us do it does sound like a
Tracy Morgan doesn't sound like whatever
Lincoln vampire hunter it sounds like
something Tracy would say yeah they
tried to cast Tracy first and he passed
cuz he was busy on 30 rock so my
original meeting I went in they were
like so Anthony you know Timo is Russian
this is black Russian he says so I'm
Tony I am looking to trace a Tracy
Morgan so what can you do and I say I
can I can do that right that's no
question why would not do that
yo ready this crazy man we got some
great fighters out here Oh
and I got the job off my Tracy Morgan
impersonation I don't know why but it's
a whole different movie raising up
removing someone is going to get
pregnant I'm gonna go down and get the
vampires not all vampires
[Laughter]